hello everybody my name is water barn
welcome to mol hammers
no cheating settle [ __ ] I just won this
is a shiny intro cheating son of a [ __ ]
control hello everybody my name is
markiplier welcome back to mole hammers
nice the son of a [ __ ] here but you
guys applied to ever see it cuz we're
gonna do intro for the next one no that
beat hello everybody my name is
markiplier welcome back to bowl here I
got it
I really don't want to cross the
threshold of slam
next this is like yeah this is what it
was hi-ho hi-ho it's off to work we go
heigh-ho and then I'm the greatest and
he lifted up the lady in blue stream I
just three late yeah three ladies and he
looked at a book upside down and threw
it away cuz books are for nerds need ya
work out and eat your protein you'll be
as good as Gaston hey hey what you think
you're doing lady huh you think you
wanna put oh you think you want a burger
huh wash husky for being stupid oh you
are cooking oh my god he does not like
that he is twitching like nobody's
business this is somewhat horrible but
at least he has cheese it give you to
this lady who didn't like my buck you oh
my god you ate it all this blood on the
go god markiplier why don't you start us
off all girls with 15 must sex by me Oh
God
try-try a niche the bouncer with my
mouth I like fun and games if you have
the knife pull it out I'll shoot one of
the bystanders and then you can Duke it
out with the is that is that the point
of this game awesome and every time it
was just like there are three to one
all right touch Bob for 30 seconds no do
it again this is yummy mushy ah we're
gonna play pokemon emerald green why not
doing that right now everybody
Wingardium okay Oh friends I greatly
apologize for that you started talking
all this all this Oh too much too much
okay okay thanks for watching all of the
videos in this compilation are available
in the description so check them out and
if you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more on a daily basis please
subscribe today or if you're already
subscribed share this video with a
friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye